the apple watch cannot perform certain
functions
if you have a wrist tattoo i'm not
making this up this is a real story
there's a guy from florida
and if you have a wrist
[Laughter]
if you have a wrist tattoo the ink from
a wrist tattoo apparently throws off the
sensors in the watch
so it can't track your pulse or read
your temperature
but and this is a real issue that
they're having for some wearers
but good news ladies and gentlemen apple
is aware of the problem
today they came out with a fix check it
out
your watch your lifestyle
the new apple watch won't get in the way
because you can have all the tattoos and
all the functions of the apple watch
with the new apple watch hand the
integrated titanium readout rod
will monitor your temperature and track
your pulse
no matter what makes your heart beat
[Music]
faster
[Music]
the apple watch hand it's not a glitch
if we can sell you a fix
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel
for an endless supply of me
you